et bien bonjour comment allez vous cette
intro n'a rien à voir avec mon chien et
vu que je suis complètement gaga est
attardé aussi je la fais avec lui les
amis aujourd'hui on a joué un petit jeu
narratif ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas
joué un jeu narratif la dernière fois on
avait joué à quoi un jeu ah oui il
fallait séduire une meuf et on avait
réussi totalement aux hôtes et mon
nouveau meilleur ami
my first kiss broc pourquoi je voulais
jouer à jeu déjà pas ce qui coûte 3
euros 50 et c'est pas très cher 70 ha
pour faire une vidéo sur tous et qui
parle d'un sujet qui me tient un peu à
coeur à savoir l'immigration alors les
développeurs se sont inspirés d'un
article 2 le monde qui est incroyable on
va suivre les aventures d'une migrantes
syrienne qui veut atteindre l'allemagne
c'est un article crois que je mettrais
bien dans la description si vous voulez
aller voir ça c'est riche en émotions
c'est très bien fait bravo à la
journaliste qui a fait ça le jeu là
c'est assez simple on va devoir est d
une syrienne a atteint de l'allemagne
lui donnant des conseils tout ça juste à
travers une conversation ou whatsapp
elle veut nous décrire les situations
dans lesquelles elle est on va avoir
plusieurs choix de réponses pour l'aider
et ce sera à nous de prendre les bonnes
décisions il ya vins fins différentes je
crois on va voir laquelle on va avoir
nous on a la chance de vivre dans un
pays développé où il n'y a pas de
conflit comme ça on doit pas fuir le
pays à cause d'une guerre du coup là on
va un peu se prendre la réalité dans la
gueule et je sais très bien que ça va ça
va me faire quelque chose mais là je
suis pris aujourd'hui je suis dans un
mood de jeu scénarisé
alors on y va 30 septembre 2015 10h30
deux matches j'ai entendu des bombes
est-ce que ça va oui allah soit loué ça
va je suis au magasin et toi toujours à
l'hôpital
un jeu qu'on produit par the pixel
jeunes bravo à zoug pixel junk a reçu
plein de prix d'ailleurs pour ce jeu 1
octobre d'abord maman puis 1 min plus
tard et qu'ils se barrent chez paou et
maintenant nawal comment va-t-elle état
critique elle est en réa je te jure
match elle s'en sort pas je me barre
d'ici l'europe les états-unis la chine
n'importe où je m'en fous tout sauf
sommes tous sauf la syrie voilà l'intro
qui nous met déjà bien en condition quoi
sur ce que c'est de vivre là bas c'est
parti nur 4 mars à une petite photo on
la dlc nous qui un sac à dos est ce qu
elle en train de partir ok donc là on
peut répondre qu'un truc déjà arrivé au
rendez vous ouais mais le taxi est pas
là ça commence mal tu es en avance on va
dire tu es en avance on va pas être dans
la négation va pas la stresser futur est
positif dire que j'étais stressée date
en retard par contre je suis persuadé
d'avoir vu quelque chose on va mettre un
petit smiley plutôt que de répondre
ouais si tu prenais pas d un moment
aussi niña c'est pas le moment du moins
juste il manque un truc
le passeport le billet d'avion et le
visa pour la turquie le chargeur way
sweet jean et tee-shirt de rechange
trousse de premier secours plus de
toilettes
alors qu'est ce qu'il manque on a le
choix entre une batterie de recherche
d'idées haut du dos tu sens bon les gens
sont plus gentil avec toi et et ce sera
bien pire théorique vas-y dit que je pus
haut lieu on voit un petit smiley qui
tire la langue à hay a donné qu'à voler
son téléphone bien c'est bon je crois
que je vois mon taxi
merde quoi merde le chauffeur parle d'
échanges de tirs à la frontière
est-ce que la route est bloquée il sait
pas mais le demande 25 mille de plus
pour m'amener à beyrouth prime de risque
10 sinon pour les 25000 de départ il dit
qu'il peut m'amener à damas pour prendre
un bus ok qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce
que l'on mène à beyrouth où est-ce qu'on
l'emmène à damas plus tard bon on va lui
demander son avis je pense que j'ai
l'impression qu'il essaie de m'arnaquer
mais que j'ai pas vraiment envie de me
prendre une balle perdue sur une
impression tu veux pas regarder s'ils
disent quelque chose d'un faux ok vas-y
toi tu as raison c'est intéressant on va
voir s'il ya vraiment des échanges
vénère il parle d'affrontements ce matin
j'arrive pas à voir ça continue mais
[ __ ] à la le premier choix du géo
nommé en pls monga le premier bon je
crois que je vais tenter damas alors non
non non mauvaise idée tu fais ça tu
risque de rater tombale huawei 90 ont
fui mais c'est risqué mais [ __ ] fait
chier de merde là ça va il est que
demain matin ça devrait le faire et puis
le bus nous coûtera toujours moins cher
que ce petit supplément à elle a
vraiment envie d'aller à damas soit elle
veut pas passer par la frontière il ya
des échanges de tirs ce que je peux tout
à fait comprendre non colo plan je sens
que damas à être le plan fois il ya un
plan qui a été établi je pense faut pas
qu'on change je sens qu'à damas mon gars
ça va être la mère devait y avoir que
des imprévus je le sens je gère hockey
ah ouais non car en fait j'ai pas le
choix quoi ça faut choyer me fallait la
fondation truc
ok comme tu veux à béziers comme tu veux
pas tenable merde mère mère m'a même
merde quoi ya pas de bus enfin si mais
pas avant demain 5 heures et l'avion et
à quelle heure 10h15 hockey dans ce
genre de situation faut juste pas
paniquer et rester droit puis je te
l'avais dit qu'à damas était la mère
[ __ ] nour
ça va ça va je pense que c'est serré
après je sais pas à quelle distance sont
les deux villes mais ça pourrait passer
oui mais le moindre incident et s'est
foutu exactement d'accord mais qu'est-ce
que je peux faire alors on verra demain
ou alors reprendre taxi franchement
reprend le taxiphone beyrouth c'est
coûtera toujours moins cher que de rater
l'avion c'est bien ça c'est bien j'aime
bien ce mec c'est bon ils arrivent ils
demandent encore vingt-cinq mille livres
1 le petit bâtard bon je suis limité nos
batteries là je vais couper le tel un
moment au quai à tout olala [ __ ] des
deux ans alors c'est la première étape
d'un long voyage ya plein de l'étape
bonsoir enfin où es tu à beyrouth dans
un hôtel oui tu vois tu t'es pas pris
deux balles
j'ai compté au moins six cafards avant
d'arriver à la chambre aa et tu
devineras jamais qui j'ai croisé camélia
c'est qui qu'a milliards mais si tu sais
la fin de mohamed cki mohamed ton cousin
et qu'ils étaient là notre mariage où
l'attend le mec il a pas l'air d'avoir
un cousin qui s'appelle mohamed c'est
quoi cette diction bizarre là c'est pas
mon cousin on était ensemble à
l'université mais voilà aussi nous on
tue pas des bêtises
mohamed il en europe waouh il a réussi à
passer à temps là on a de l'espoir là ça
nous donne beaucoup d'espoir cette
histoire il a fait la traversée en
bateau
et là il attend d'obtenir l'asile en
angleterre camélia m'a donné son nouveau
numéro pour que je puisse lui demander
des conseils
on a aidé istanbul parce qu'elle a
traversés faisait peur mais si mohamed a
des contacts de passeur et tout c'est
peut-être le plus simple du coup à la
gemme pas changé les plans des revenus
je suis tellement pas partisan de ça
c'est terrible se trouve il a juste eu
beaucoup de chance et j'ai hâte que tu
me rejoignent ils s'aiment et ou allez
allez allez ça va aller vous allez
réussir on va tomber sur la fin heureuse
où ils ont des bébés et les enfants vont
à l'école pendant que il son pdg d'une
grande entreprise c'est la presse
indique je passe loin de toi ça fait
bizarre tient une une petite photo m
quand on voit une petite photo tu
morangis des ronflements aussi au hockey
deux jours plus tard le 5 mars salle et
j'espère qu'elle va pouvoir entrer dans
la vie on va pas avoir un problème à la
douane rouge pas quoi oui salle
d'embarquement je voulais pas te
réveiller alors est ce qu'il a vu a du
retard ou pas ça qu'on veut savoir est
ce que tout se passe bien dit nous nous
rassure nous non tout va bien nickel ça
me fait juste bizarre veut dire que dans
quatre heures j'aurais changé de
continent on se reparle à mon arrivée
parfait elle nous fait le smiley bisous
coeur qu'on apprécie tanger une réponse
de mohamed
il m'a fait le contact du passeur qu'il
a fait traverser à izmir et donner le
nom du quartier où faut aller bassmann
ça s'appelle pour [ __ ] attend faut
raisonner selon vous c'est quoi le mieux
c'est de faire claque bim par la mer ou
claque bim par la terre la mer les
bateaux ils sont blindés à tout moment
et risque de couler alors que la terre
ça paraît un peu plus safe mais il n'y a
pas un peu plus de contrôles au niveau
de la terre qu'au niveau de la mer je
sais pas on lui dit laisse tomber suit
le plan ouais non mais je pensais le
mieux je pense faut pas changer le plan
vraiment aller bon vol nous renvoie le
dois bien me soit bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok on a des news allait arriver en
turquie est la cunca pis le chauffeur la
navette n'a déposé là sans que je
demande rien je crois que je commence à
comprendre pourquoi il n'y a pas un seul
turquie si que des africains des
migrants ou des touristes j'étais à
peine sorti que dix mecs me sont tombés
dessus pour vendre des cartes sim monde
est dans des callshops méfie-toi
attention on vient de lui dire de cacher
son argent parce que là bas ils savent
qu'il ya des gens qui ont de la thune
sur eux pour pouvoir atteindre l'europe
et du coup ils se font voler donc faut
qu'elles trouvent une astuce on lui dit
dans la doublure ou dans les chaussures
dans la doublure c'est mieux que les
chaussures à mais si tu perds ta baisse
non mais tu peux perdre thales pourquoi
ça c'est un sens dans une doublure ce
pas mal dans la chaussure ce trop
classique quelque chose je supporte
toujours sur toi voilà c'est bien ça je
peux défaire les coutures de mon
soutien-gorge maintenant banon aulas il
est sur moi mais je peux trouver une
aiguille du filet des toilettes dans
l'après midi
ok très bien très bien alors bon là il
est bon faut que tu le caches un peu
mieux quand même des gens m'ont abordé
pour tout un tas de trucs mais pas de
passeurs merde je crois que c'est plus
dans une ville qui s'appelle et diane
que ça se passe où là c'est loin
[ __ ] elle est là il faut qu'elle aille
là est ce qu'on lui dit d'attendre ce
soir où est ce qu'on lui dit d'y aller
maintenant vas-y en plein jour un mois
j'ai d'évasion plein jour j'ai pas envie
de rester ici toute façon je parle pas
la langue je connais personne et je le
sens pas ce quartier ok suit son
instinct
elle n'est pas contente [ __ ] il se
basait quoi pétage de câble ils veulent
pas me vendre de billets pourrait dire
non mais t'as un visa tu as quand même
le droit de déplacer en turquie oui mais
pas trop près des frontières apparemment
[ __ ] j'en étais sûr qu la terre ça
allait faire chier au niveau des
frontières et c'est un autre guichet
parce que tu crois que j'ai pas essayé
je ne sais pas nous reparlons autrement
nour s'il te plaît enfin j'essaie de t&d
voyons je suis allé voir trois mecs et
nanas j'ai joué la police j'ai crié j'ai
même fait mes yeux de chien battu
on entretient battus et nourris ça
marche à chaque fois barré du thème
disent tous la même chose note ulrich
nautique est en plus le but c'est juste
là je pourrai grave tenter de monter
quand même maintenant c'est la pire
chose à [ __ ] je sais pas est ce qu'on
y va au culot tu monte dans le bus sans
ticket ouais mais tu vas te faire
contrôler ils vont te tais tu vas finir
en prison chez paou ne fait pas ça c'est
la police te tombe dessus visa ou pas
visage tu risques d'avoir des problèmes
ouais y'a un quartier d'istanbul
surnommé little syria c'est peut-être un
bon endroit pour commencer à chercher
ok je lui ai conseillé de chercher un
restaurant qui part où elle peut
rencontrer des mecs pour lui donner des
bons tuyaux
je suis dans une sorte de salon de thé
librairie salle de concert d'accord truc
ambidextre à 100% en tout cas les gens
sont super sympas ils ont l'habitude
d'accueillir les voyageurs syrien des
gemmes confirmé qu'airbus était morne
qui laisse monter que les turcs mais du
coup il ya des passeurs qui peuvent le
conduire d'ici à edern après faut passer
la frontière à pied est mohammad connaît
quelqu'un oui il est super stylé
excellent j'ai confiance en cet homme
auquel va dormir dans une chambre
d'hôtel à elle veut profiter de sa
soirée hockey espérons que ce soit bien
passé je suis avec mohammad là et son
ami le passeur à une bonne nouvelle ça
il dit qu'il connaît les bons endroits à
la frontière bulgare il m'emmène là bas
ils me laisserais assez tout seul et je
paye que si j'arrive bien de l'autre
côté vers ça en fait je laisse l'argent
à mohammad et si j'arrive de l'autre
côté je lui envoie un message pour qu'il
le donne aux pacers sinon il me le garde
au chaud à istanbul
quoi mais moi ma tu le connais depuis
depuis 12 heures qu'est ce tu veut lui
confier l'argent et lui donner le rôle
du mec qu'ils donnent aux pacers si
l'adversaire a marché ou pas ça se
trouve le pasteur c'est juste un
complice de mohammad et les arnaques
tous les syriens qui passe par là mais
enfin nous revoyons je comprends ce que
tu veux dire mais je pense que je peux
faire confiance à mohammad
il a déjà été plein de gens qu'est ce
que tu en sais mais c'est vrai nous on
fait gaffe ya des humains ils sont
fourbes un tout ça pour dire que moi je
lui fais confiance tu peux me faire
confiance à moi ok on parle de combien
du cou avait combien ça coûte alors
1500 sonné tout c'est trop cher mais
mais qu'est ce que c'est j'ajoute une
valeur des choses sur ça va être le seul
blême c'est qu'une fois que tu as agent
est encore loin de l'allemagne
il tracera 1200 pour tous a du mal à y
croire bon de toute façon le départ et
pas avant ce soir c est le temps tu
renseigner ailleurs hockey ouais voit
toutes les options avant haussmann peut
pas ce soir finalement non sa voiture
doit être plein j'aurais dû lui dire oui
macho merde j'ai déconné ok la prime est
passée à nous dit qu'elle n'a pas trouvé
mieux que le plan de mohammad donc on va
juste prier pour que demain haussmann
nous emmène oh là là tantôt tom hayden
nous fait une phase là elle a passé sa
soirée avec mohammad est tous là dans le
cabaret chez pas quoi elle écrit comme
une meuf bout réel et el dia ce
portfolio dire propos elle double les
lettres ça faut pas être inspecteur
squeeze pour comprendre qu'est l'alcool
là dedans et elle nous dit et si j
allais pas qu'est ce qui t'arrive là et
si je restais là en syrie en turquie tu
veux dire elle est complètement bourré
lé rebbouh l'alcool est dangereux pour
la santé
on n'a pas à se répéter à nour nour tu
as bu oui elle est honnête j'aime bien
un peu à elle est un peu malhonnête
j'aime moi je te rappelle que c'est
contraire à ta religion pas la mienne je
suis athée mois auquel par un discours
de me fourrer là c'est insupportable je
fais encore dormir que discuter à
quelqu'un de penmarch en eau à lyon mais
plainte est le pot c'est horrible vous
avez vu comme c'est horrible de parler à
quelqu'un de bourg et quand toi t'es pas
bourré c'est la pire chose est dans la
vraie vie c'est encore pire
coucou madame fait la grasse matinée
[ __ ] 11h40 à bien d'autres alors
est-ce que ce soir tu vas pouvoir passer
dit nounours ok elle a rendez vous avec
le passeur dans huit heures donc à 19h40
et elle a oublié de mettre son fan a
chargé hier soir en mai n'ont put un
moment ça va couper mais qu'on mette en
pls on n'aura plus de nouvelles ça va
couper au moment où elle va partir avec
le passeur c'est sûr c'est bon je sais
je vais le laisser à la librairie en
attendant je reviens chercher après on
va te le volet hockey le lendemain
[ __ ] on n'a pas une news jusqu'au
lendemain
bon bah voilà je suis en voiture en
liesse voyons voir si elle arrive à
passer maintenant au [ __ ] je viens
d'arriver
le tchèque nous a lâchés dans la forêt
maintenant faut marcher way passer cette
frontière passée cette frontière
ça va aller je sais pas on voit que
dalle aux rameurs je viens de me
ramasser par terre n'ont pas ce
permalien d'écrire en marchant dans le
noir bon excusez moi mais du coup faut
pas que je perde les autres où elle suit
les deux préaux ne répond pas mais le
portable répond pas aux quais deux
heures plus tard nous envoie sa test je
voulais voir si j'avais encore du réseau
s'est passé ou pas au nom il ya un
problème
zineb veut faire une pause knight ça va
il a 12 ans il trotte mais elle elle
galère avec le bébé le problème c'est
qu'un manuel est déjà loin devant et
comme on peut pas crier
[ __ ] qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce qu
elle rejoint emmanuel qui a un grand
baraqué ou est ce qu'elle reste avec
zenab et son bébé
[ __ ] je sais pas franchement c'était
un rêve et je me serais dit à ma meuf
qui est hyper loin de moi elle est au
milieu d'une forêt il fait une nuit elle
en train de passer une frontière
franchement rattraper manuel ma puce je
veux qu'il survive je peux pas les
laisser aux souris bribes la pire chose
j'ai rattrapé emmanuel je me déteste tu
dois d'abord penser à toi c'est horrible
mais c'est vrai quoi c'est horrible mais
c'est vrai là pour vraiment quoi
emmanuel va vite faut que je te laisse
je te raconterai tout demain suit le
serbe bonhomme ce manuel c'est un
bonhomme ou là ok donc c'était à 6
heures son dernier message à 21h on lui
demande des nouvelles rentes heures sans
news alors est-ce que ça va ça va tout
va bien elle a passé la frontière du
moins oui mieux que ça je suis à sofia
or oui et on a fait la moitié du chemin
mon gars [ __ ] désolé pater contacter
avant tout est allé super vite
on vient de se poser pour la première
fois dans un hôtel pourri mais à des
prises et du wifi je suis toujours avec
emmanuel très bien très bien j'adore
c'est emmanuel il n'a pas d'argent alors
on partage la chambre a c'est plus mon
pote je le déteste vraiment on est
encore en train de récents dans la forêt
quand un truc des chiens au loin mais
pas trop loin emmanuel m'adapter à un
arm mais lui a pas eu le temps avant que
les mecs arrivent c'était pas la police
pas l'armé non plus juste des mecs je
comprenais rien à ce qu'il disait mais
il avait l'air vénère moi j'ai passé le
reste de la nuit dans l'arbre sur
descendu qu il a commencé à faire jour
j'ai continué tout droit et je suis
retombé sur un manuel en train de boiter
il avait réussi à échapper aux mecs mais
pas trop aux chiens ils ont déchiré le
mollet j'ai fait ce que je pouvais comme
bordage n'a connu à marcher jusqu'à
trouver une sorte de parking y avait un
pick up avec une bâche on s'est mis sous
la bâche on a attendu en espérant que
quelqu'un arrive et conduit ce truc vers
le nord ce qui s'est passé n'est
descendu à sofia jusqu'à présent je
tenais avec l'adrénaline mais là je sens
que tout mon corps lâche
repose-toi l'hôtel repose fait une bonne
nuit de 10 heures la bim désolé de pas
trop avoir la force de discuter ce
paravent ce pas on s'en fout
[Musique]
ces manuels on est loin de macron alors
vous fait quoi là une station-service on
a passé la frontière serbe j'ai fait
deux courses à acheter une sim
j'ai pas trop le temps de t'expliquer on
va repartir bientôt mais en gros on a
trouvé 1 km pour passer la frontière
nous amener à belgrade
quel genre de camions à rome un camion
en fait tu vois la remorque pour
transporter les chevaux ça fera le teint
bien arrivé à belgrade
ok ils ont affrété des bus ndi djassa se
disputent pour savoir s'il faut les
prendre non plein de gens ne peuvent
déjà plus marcher à merde ça ressemble à
quoi si on s'arrête maintenant déjà que
la moitié des gens sont déjà dans les
bus
emmanuel compris au nom emmanuel a lâché
il préfère tenter sa chance par la
croatie elle nous envoie une petite
photo son ensemble ils sont posés motivé
vous les uns les autres quand tu me
trouves tu es magnifique tu es vraiment
la lumière qui illumine les jours sans
soleil et sous la prairie des brumes
endiablé jeu 120 sacs à patates menant
un sac carrefour
olala ça part en couille son truc tout
le monde commence à s'engueuler et
toutes les familles partent pour la
croatie au lieu d'atteindre la hongrie
comme prévu initialement mais rebond a
trouvé une carte sur internet avec des
zones rouges là où il ya le moins de
surveillance à la frontière
il reste le tiers du groupe [ __ ] ils
sont plus que 108 300 c'est pas sûr
qu'on tienne encore un jour de marche
allez courage nour courage on va
s'arrêter là pour la nuit on aurait
passé avant-hier demain midi ok je crois
qu'on est plus long de la frontière pas
de barbelés pas de police rire ça va
être facile soit présente à temps et
peut-être un piège quatre heures plus
tard et ben les champs de mines c'est
plus ce que c'était on est tous entier
no mais il faudrait qu'ils prennent une
mine c'est ce que je disais les zones
pas surveiller non [ __ ] mais c'est
risque est là quand même
on a trouvé une station-service on va
pouvoir refaire le plein ah vous avez
une voiture le plein de batteries banane
acp et de on a plus d'eau c'est embêtant
ça allez courage nous rebute inquiet
presse plus qu'un pays à passer je pense
qu'on va essayer de faire du stop
alors on a le choix soit on lui
conseille de chercher les plaques
étrangères soit d'aller vers les camions
les cas mais on sait bien les camions
j'ai trouvé un chauffeur un camionneur
et bavois la [ __ ] mais oui mais c'est
ça les bonnes décisions
maj de match match bachelot ce vers quoi
je vais en allemagne qua non ibrahim le
chauffeur quand je lui ai expliqué que
je voulais aller en allemagne
il m'a sorti genre bah pourquoi tu l'a
pas dit plus tôt je vais jusqu'à munich
mois non il n'a pas peur de se faire
arrêter aux frontières bah écoutes je
préférais pas en parler des fois que ça
me ferait changer d'avis mais je pense
qu il est pas con non plus on va bientôt
arriver en slovénie [ __ ] ça va
tellement vite la fête s'accélère on
approche du péage de la frontière je
vais passer à l'arrière ouais et on est
repassé devant [ __ ] ça s'accélère la
queue du bol quand même de tomber sur
les brahim normand les gens font payer
pour faire passer les frontières
oui et c'est d'ailleurs très bizarre je
me demande si a pas anguille sous roche
je crois que j'ai pas encore bien
réaliser que d'ici 3 4 h et en allemagne
[ __ ] je sens le la merde c'est trop
facile la mhd comment on dit prise
électrique en allemand ah non elle est
en autriche est né en autriche et sans
batterie je suis descendu du camion
pourquoi il va t'amener à munich
ibrahim a mis la main sur la cuisse
alors j'ai piqué une crise jusqu'à ce
qu'il arrête le camion voilà je l'avais
dit en plus tout à l'heure que les
camionneurs il est des fois attention à
le cliché ok elle est pas très loin de
vienne dans une chambre d'hôte dans un
bled qui s'appelle cib oden [ __ ] t'as
plus qu'une frontière de merde avant
d'aller en allemagne je viens de monter
en voiture là je voulais pas te
réveiller un couple de vieux m'a prise
en stop
j'adore les vieux à moi j'adore les
vieux alors elle leur a demandé de la
déposer à la gare j'ai à peine eu le
temps de me prendre un petit truc à
manger à la guerre que des militaires me
sont tombés dessus
ils ont contrôlé tes papiers n'ont même
pas ils m'ont fait sortir la gare est
mise dans un bus et je sais pas où il
nous emmène en allemagne bizarrement je
crois pas une seule seconde [ __ ] merde
non ça c'était si bien là tout se
passait si bien [ __ ] du mois que c'est
bon du moins que c'est bon
bon bah tout va bien ah c'est juste un
camp de transit
ils ont mis des lits de camp dans un
hangar quoi ils nous ont même rapproché
de la frontière or apparemment on est
libre on peut partir si on veut trop
cool et steyn raison de rester ou pas
pas vraiment alors dégagé feu en
allemagne ok elle a plus beaucoup de
batteries [ __ ] arrive au bout là on
arrive au bout de ça y est c'est la fin
du voyage théâtre en allemagne oui
[Musique]
je t'aime nour je suis dans un
commissariat la y avait des policiers
qui gardaient la frontière après la
signent mais moi ils m'ont laissé passer
j'étais la seule femme c'est peut-être
pour ça et du coup ils m'ont amené ici
tu as pu faire ta demande d'asile
pas encore [ __ ] c'est quoi cette
histoire hockey le lendemain nous répond
que le lendemain à eau un truc audio cd
j'ai l'impression que ça fait un bail
que j'en avais pas longtemps désolé pour
l'absence de nouvelles mais c'est un peu
compliqué ces derniers jours c'est pas
encore ça demande d'asile va être
acceptée mais en attendant ils m'ont mis
dans un sac pour femmes dans un petit
village et j'ai ma propre chambre
j'espère vraiment vraiment vraiment
qu'ils vont être envoyés maintenant je
rejoigne
je pense que ça cléry d'accord c'est pas
la série mais en attendant c'est l'heure
de manger on se reparle plus tard
d'autres voire fin pour nourrir le
voyage se termine ici mais si vous le
souhaitez vous pouvez désormais
recommencer au début et peut-être
changer son destin on a réussi on a
réussi eh ben elle atteint l'allemagne
teint mais ce que rim c'est qu'on sait
pas si si vous la renvoyez ou pas quoi
elle est en attente on a réussi à la
hâte en allemagne mais on sait pas si
elle va pas être intérieur après quoi
hausse était fou est bon les amis c'est
la fin de ce tuyau c'est naze et
n'hésitez pas à mes abdos ciel vous a
plu c'est très touchant je trouve juste
de de voir comment ça se passe une
traversée comment ça se passe quand dans
ton pays c'est la merde et que tu t'en
vient carrément à le fuir mais que sur
ton chemin avaya voir vraiment des
étapes c'est vraiment intéressant de
voir ce que c'est le côté bon même si
c'est scénarisé il ya une histoire
d'amour mais mais je vais à des millions
de gens qui ont vraiment existé et qui
sont passés par là en fait part juste
essayé de d'atteindre une zone de où ils
craignent pas pour leur vie où ils n'ont
pas peur qu'une bombe leur tombe dessus
sur sa super de la part de cette
journaliste d'avoir fait un article
comme ça juste à l'aide des
conversations whatsapp que qu'ils
avaient entre la morale c'est pas se
dire mais ce qu'est pays doivent
accepter les réfugiés ou pas bla bla on
est très loin de ça là c'est juste une
histoire de ce que ces gens ont vécu ce
par quoi ils sont passés et quand tu
vois des réfugiés syriens sont en france
battait loin d'imaginer ce qu'ils ont
vécu en fait t'es vraiment loin
d'imaginer et essaye mais tu peux tu
peux pas en fait c'est tellement énorme
peu
voilà j'espère que ça vous aura plu je
vous dis à trier dans une prochaine
vidéo ça me tenait à coeur de faire ce
jeu encore bravo développeurs et voilà
merci à vous d'avoir regardé c'était
long portez vous bien sûr tout le monde
j'attends avec notre souhait à bois mais
une prochaine fois
[Musique]